each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
human problem and also there's certainly
a lot of issues with finding what's the
question to this if I need to go to
market you get something that's not an
apple or pear you came back there are
you going but of course that's perfectly
kind of new languages because not I'm
the apple there after if Nick was often
done in natural language style people
seem to be thinking of their data more
like lists and my crazed and sensitive
room for sausages and then inexpensive
XO objects have the entities that people
talk about how pocket light
characteristics in the sense that they
remember something about themselves and
remember their activities there they go
these are not suit you talk pac-man as
an entity and what is you do so those
are some of the just a few of the adults
we have we use these as a way of signing
a new environment that was primarily the
kids I have a bunch of other interesting
properties that the data was presented
on card so all data was always visible
was invisible video election law systems
but indeed which is so foggy here is a
person who's executing your program and
you can click on him to see a spa hole
is just a photo the code is kind of
natural language style like Oh scrapped
or you know flash and there are some
dimensions of the operations that are
useful for a duration like moving
and so forth and anything that can you
doing singleton use you on set so their
buoys to return sets about it so you can
say set buzzing direction 19 which that
one be but you could also say set all
B's an idea or set all these who you
know love you know 20 or some property
like that and that would work exactly
the same way and there's a video online
if you want to see more about it but I'm
going to move on to more new stuff so
what we're doing now moving on from the
language is looking more at the
programming environment looking at tools
that are equivalent of visual studio or
flash or things like that and look at
can we use the same methods about
studying programmer studying what people
do as a way of improving the programming
process for whatever language you're
using whether it's a c-sharp or visual
basic or flash or anything like that and
again we're taking the same steps we're
studying what people do we develop
systems inspired by the observation to
what people do and then we try and
evaluate the results to make sure we're
there and in this work we're targeting
both novice and expert programmers end
user programmers novice or beginning
programmers you know students and
professional programmers and we have
about five studies one new tool lots of
new ideas and you'll see kind of the top
kind of ends right in the middle because
we've done only studies we got was great
ideas and what rate in the middle of
trying to implement them if they were so
the first thing we did was studied some
people in the Alice environment which
was done by a colleague of mine Randy
Pausch and it's a basically a toy
programming environment for doing 3d
animations and we we liked it because it
uses a drag-and-drop style so if you
want code you drag it out of here and
drop it into the code window and if you
want to edit it you kind of drop it out
the advantage of that of course is you
can't make syntax errors to a lot of the
kind of errors that the inner programmer
would make are gone and an expert
programmer
using this can program you know a
stantial amount of code fairly quickly
if you know anything about syntax
editors it's really good for creating
code quickly and it's really terrible
for maintenance really terrible for
editing okay but we were doing a pretty
much study of creating code and so you
know that kind of had a good pick up so
the advantage was in a to our study we
could see lots of stuff happening where
if you you know took on a beginner in
c-sharp environment and two hours
nothing too much would have happened
alice is optimized for creating 3d
animations and there are all sorts of
other things that it protects against
the other nice thing but out of Alice of
course we could get in there and change
the execution model change the code
because we have you know all the source
locally and a lot of extra key so we
studied we say what we said oh three
experts and for novice programmers over
the course of about a month and almost
900 minutes of observations and there
were lots and lots of problems as you
might imagine not pretty surprising and
we you know define break down to
situations where the programmer was
confused about what happened 102 of
these cause errors a lot of the errors
went to more errors and in fact that was
one of our interesting findings is that
they were often these long chains of
breakdowns where somebody would make an
error they were tried and fix it that
would generate more errors in the code
and in fact the average chain at 2.3
breakdown so though almost every case
when there was never it caused at least
one more error of my is the 33 included
in the 102 yes overall almost fifty
percent of the program's time was spent
during debugging and this is in spite of
the fact that you know the compiler was
I mean there no compiler Stefan that all
these other kinds of errors were
eliminated and the tasks were fairly
simple and the neat thing well is to
focus on this more we took all of these
observations of all these errors and
classified them
into different categories yeah Rob so on
the previous line can you say a little
bit more precisely what means
what did you count this is bugging as
opposed to what were the other
activities what's the yeah we'll get
that you'll see you'll see in this
basically we have this model of all the
things that breakdowns happened and all
of all the activities that people did
and we classified the problems into
three different groups knowledge
problems which is when they didn't know
something attentional problems which was
when you know kind of did something and
strategic problems or when they kind of
don't know how to do something and so we
we developed this model of all the
things that happen and so the you have
breakdowns it can be a knowledge problem
intentional problem or strategic problem
and that repeats and all these in the
specification time the implementation
time or debugging time and
implementation problems can lead to
errors errors can lead to false and
false and leads to failure so an error
is when you make a mistake in the code a
fault is a faulty data inside the code
somewhere and a failure is when it's
something on the output that you're
actually notice and so sometimes you
don't notice sometimes in more than one
error that caused the fault and things
like that so here's an example they were
trying to check in a pacman game when
all the dots were eaten okay and that's
kind of tricky a boolean logic to create
and so they created it wrong and so they
were had a trouble creating the boolean
logic because they didn't really know
how to do it and the result was that
they implemented it wrong and they
actually made two errors so errors are
look like this so they have two
different errors in the code the effect
was that the conditional came true
before was supposed to and pac-man
bounces before all the dots work on that
would be effect and so then they tried
to figure out why that happened but they
made an error in figuring that out
because they couldn't really tell what
was going on and so they modified the
wrong thing and as a result they added
in a new error and so on and so they you
know actually made the code worse and it
goes on and on and eventually they give
up life have been different bigger
probably Toronto if they have been
allowed to make all the other kinds of
errors that were being prevented from
the toy environment yeah so there
probably would be more lots and lots
more problems in the implementation
implementing section because other we've
made all these compile-time error kind
of things syntax errors and they
basically you know would be making
zillions of those and you know basically
just slowing them down this based on
expert programmers behavior yet no no we
basically just kind of use this as a way
of analyzing this particular study and
motivating the next one but you know
it's certainly out there if somebody
wants to look at what it might be useful
for and another thing that we observed
was that all of the debugging problems
that they had I'm sorry Rob did that
answer question or basically you know
they spent a lot of time trying to
figure out what happened and you know
and that something else will get to is
you know they were trying to figure out
what algorithms derive even I'm not
coming were you asking what what
happened so so so your colleague Bob
Harper has this funny phrase about
students they like to debug programs
into existence right and so I'm trying
to account for this forty six percent
like how much of so presumably a bug is
any deviation from the spec they were
given on what they were supposed to
accomplish well it was actually what
they have in mind to do at the
particular time so so I'm trying to get
a few houses forty-six percent i would
actually think i was just sort of
creating
the program is trying to get it to do
any little thing and then build upon
that to get to do the thing I real not
like how much of that is you know
chasing down things that are obvious
bugs right like something doesn't show
up on the screen right I think in this
in this time well if you're trying to
divide the forty-six percent into what
are the different aspects of that you
know that's what the models were
supposed to do the other fifty-four
percent of time was spent you know
reading the specification and typing and
stuff and dragging and dropping him back
so pretty much from the first when they
ran as soon as they started running the
code and discovered it didn't do exactly
what they had mine that's when this
clock started
so the interesting thing that we
discovered it wasn't much surprising to
me but was surprising to andy was that
virtually all of the debugging sessions
the bugging issues could be answered by
why questions you know why did this
happen why didn't this happen and you
know why why is this object not moving a
little surprising was it almost
two-thirds over two-thirds of the
questions were not questioned why did
something not happen okay which you know
as you may know today's dividing tools
are particularly you know inappropriate
for answering you know you put a
breakpoint and sure enough it's not
reached that was helpful so our thought
was how we could enable people to
directly ask why questions in the user
interface itself in the programming
environment and then you know provide
answers in terms of the code and the
execution history why do we think we can
do why not questions well that's because
people even though some of these were
novices did not expect their code to do
stuff that they didn't have they haven't
written yet okay so they weren't that
novice you know so they only really
asked why not questions about things
that could have happened code they wrote
but wasn't executed for some reason and
so that's something you can analyze
right they didn't ask you know you know
how come I'm not being served dinner
because you know they hadn't written any
code for that and the air and the way
that we're implementing this is it
behind the scenes every single action is
being walked every single variable being
changed every execution call and then
we're doing what's called slices along
backwards chains from the place where
the code stops to look at causes and
things that either happened it didn't
happen the answers use a text message a
visualization we call the y line which
shows both data flow and control folded
lead up to certain situations and then
highlighting of the code and data that's
relevant to whatever pops up let me run
the video
the wire line is a new debugging tool
that lets programmers ask questions
about their programs output and behavior
we have further typed the Y line in the
Alice programming environment which has
been designed to help create interactive
3d simulations and animations Alice
supports dragons of the rational
technique for editing code which
represents all syntax and tigers will
use this pac-man program to demonstrate
the Y line will go through three
examples of how a programmer will call
Ellen use the wild line to help or
implement various parts of the game in
our first example Alan is trying to make
back my move forward like this first she
clicks on Pacman in the object list and
creates a new method called move back
this will execute all of pac-man's
animations as the program runs she then
drags a move animation to the move pack
method and chooses for three years per
second as parameters she can test your
program by pressing the play button but
that doesn't move the numbers typically
respond to this type of failure by
asking why didn't pick my move picking
up with several possible explanations on
average it took programmers two to three
minutes to diagnose this failure with
the wine line however value so quick why
didn't it work what else hey good
failure was quite simple she clicks on
the Y button which one is the program
and brings up a hierarchical menu of why
did and why did questions why did menu
is generated from all of the changes to
output that were executed while the
program is running and the why did the
menu is generated from all of all civil
changes to output in the program whether
or not they executed Ellen juices why
didn't pack move forward three from the
menu and as she does so the
corresponding output statement is
highlighted in the code editor the lines
answer indicates why the heck move
forward never gets executed it says that
the mood statement only happens when the
move back method happens but nothing
makes move pack happen this is an
example of an invariant answer in which
some output statement always or never
occurs to fix this error Ellen creates a
new event
calm move map Wally Alice program is
running she then test the change impact
my moves as expected in our second
example Helen wants to make black man
shrink if he touches the ghost as shown
here to do this she creates a deity
other statement which executes some
multiple statements concurrently she
looks the animation inside of it she
then adds an if statement which checks
the ghost is within a certain distance
of black man she does this ladies and
one of the ghosts questions which is
called is within threshold she guesses
that community should be the right she
then drags a resize animation so that if
magnin is close enough to the ghost back
then we'll resize to nothing she
indicates this choosing a resize factor
of zero when she tests the new code that
can clearly intersects the ghost that
doesn't seem to be sized at all Ellen
asks why didn't I can reset to zero the
Y line answers by saying that Batman did
in fact resize and it shows the
visualization of the events that
happened at runtime that caused him to
do so this is an example of a false and
proposition answer the question that
Ellen asked implicitly assumed that the
resize did not occur when in fact it did
note that even though the resized did
occur she was still able to find this
question in the why did menu allowing
questions with files from our positions
allows the wireline to reveal
programmers false assumptions about
their programs execution Ellen can drag
the time cursor in order to swept
through the execution history and see
that pac-man didn't factory size as a
result of the AIDS within threshold
expression evaluating to true case the
wireline held zelin limit the failure to
the resize statement she decides to try
unknown 0 blabber element tests this
change in pac-man resizes as expected it
turns out that in Ellis resizing 20 has
no effect
oh nice to prevent back from shrinking
he's even been God and seen here has
anybody ever found something like that
in the Microsoft API that some
interesting parameter control something
you didn't expect only wants to prevent
back from shrinking and has even been
god and seen here she has another
innovative to do together missile test
if crack is within wonder of the big dog
if this becomes true they will set the
big dots is showing property to false
which will cause it to disappear on
screen and indicate that it has been
eaten in the code chicken elaborates the
ghost collision conditional to prevent
pac-man from resizing if the big dot has
been eating
Alan test the changes notice is that
even though pac-man obviously eats the
big God he still resizes when he touched
the ghost Ellen simply asks why okay any
theories it's actually a very
complicated pac-man resized in this case
the Y line shows all of the control and
data flow actions causing the resize to
occur including the if statement and the
expressions evaluated as part of the
urgent as Alan selects different events
in the visualization the code
corresponding to the action is
highlighted automatically in the code
editor once Ellen notices that adopted
showing was true when the conditional
was evaluated she says to herself wait I
saw the big dot disappear this should an
adventurer she that asks why didn't we
got these showing changes in the context
of this question the Sultan
visualization combines the results of
the two questions and explains that the
data is showing did change to false Alan
choices backwards from the resize
noticing that the two conditionals were
interleaved the second conditional began
to execute before the first conditional
was complete to attend this interleaving
she stops programmer moves the big dot
collision tests before they do together
to ensure that it gets executed before
the other test does Batman becomes
invincible when he eats the big dot as
expected this was the multi-process and
user studies comparing Alice with the
while into Alice without the wireline
the oil and decrease debugging time by
an average factor of eight and helped
program is complete forty percent more
tasks than users without the y line in
the same amount of time we are currently
investigating ways to extend the Y line
to more professional programming
languages and environments and even to
desktop applications such as word
processors and email clients so just to
reiterate the really dramatic results
that we got is that we had a factor of
eight speed up in debugging time and
significantly more reliable code of the
people weren't adding extra errors into
their programs as a result of trying to
remove other errors and as a result
their overall programmer productivity
was about forty percent higher so that's
a you know really exciting results and
we wanted to see you know does this
technique scale up to professional
programming environment C sharp for Java
or whatever and so the next step was
obviously to rebuild the white line into
a professional environment but along the
way we got sidetracked by lots of other
questions so we still haven't answered
that one yet and that one's still
pending you know I just a quick question
about the design of a while on and one
of the things I find interesting about
it is you have two representations of
the program right the one in the middle
is actually like the source code right
the one at the bottom is a concrete
execution right this creates for the
program our kind of correspondence
problem how do I figure out what a
bubble or you know a moment in time
there corresponds to the one of the
source text because that's where I have
to change the behavior so it seems like
I guess for your users that wasn't a big
deal is it well we did a lot of waited a
lot of work as you notice here this guy
is selected and the equivalent piece of
code is selected so and also if you
notice when you click on the why menu
itself it actually highlights the code
that corresponds to each line there and
we found actually that sometimes people
didn't even have to ask the question
they could just look at the menus and by
being able to ask the why questions and
seeing what code was highlighted
sometimes that was even enough the we
did I mean because the code here is
coordinated by color if you notice it's
the same color it's coordinated by name
so that it uses the same terminology it
graphically looks the same use the same
terminology and any time you click on
something it moves the code to the right
place we didn't see that being a big
problem what was a big problem is that
code that executes a whole bunch of
times you'd end up with a long string of
them and then it's tricky to figure out
you know which one the Cockney mouse
good point you made it look kind of
questions and I someone which one of you
have any insight about the ability for
users with this environment or absolute
professional program funds that they'll
give people to ask the right question
well one of the key issues about scaling
up right as to what extent we're going
to be able to make sure their questions
are in the list right and we found it
about ninety-five percent of the time
the questions that they wanted to ask
we're indeed in the list and you know
all of the questions well observation
was that people wanted to ask questions
about the output about things they saw
in the environment because this was a
highly graphical application and the
behaviors they want we're all expressed
graphically and so it made a lot of
sense to ask about things that happened
in the scene and usually it wasn't a
problem knowing what they want to ask
about because they want to ask about why
something didn't happen in the scene
when you scale up to a professional
environment where things are more hidden
and you're talking about internal stuff
and it'll be more interesting to see if
we can have the right questions in the
menus but we did the times when the
right questions weren't in the menus
where cases where the why light and
really wouldn't help because they had
designed their you know boolean logic
incorrectly and so sure enough they knew
this piece of code had executed and they
knew it was wrong but they didn't really
know how to fix it and you know so those
are the kind of things that this really
isn't designed to help with but I think
the challenge is getting the right
questions in the menus rather than
having the programmer recognize the
questions when they're there mr. Bandini
examination is how does would scale to
to a more layout driven programming burn
like adil on this card data driven
people are now trying to figure out how
to debug a hierarchical layout of things
are relatively recent originally yeah
that's more of a constraint debugging
problem and we've done other work not
related to this that really looks it
more debugging of declarative things
like constraints and things about
visualizing data flows and that kind of
stuff colleague of mine bread banders in
and have an interesting cool about that
a few years ago but that would be
interesting to think about it you know
exploring how that connects with this
because certainly this data flow kind of
thing is useful a market brunette that
Oregon State has done a bunch stuff with
spreadsheets which are very similar to
you know data flow kind of things where
it's all about constraints and and
layout you know is all about how the
values go from place to place I think
that would be an interesting thing to
look at to see if that the same
visualizations would work or whether you
want to do something else but I think in
terms of the you know the concept that
what you want to ask about is things
that happened in terms of layout and
wise it's here and stuff like that is
really interesting and we're doing some
current research this summer to look at
focusing the questions based on being
able to point of stuff you know so if
you could say why is this here then that
would really help with making sure the
menus have the right thing okay another
study we did was looking at more on
learning it turned out coincidentally at
the same time I was teaching a class on
HCI to a bunch of people who didn't know
how to program and they were learning
visual basic and flash during the course
of this course and Andy was one of my PS
and so we took advantage of that to do a
bunch of studies of the problems they
have and try and reflect on what we can
learn from that looking at the prior
literature on learning
it was an enormous amount of work on how
people learn to program done in the
early 80s and but surprisingly most of
it was about programming language kind
of things you know what syntax people
have trouble with and what sort of you
know for loops and stuff like that
virtually nothing about the editor
debugger the help system there are
messages all this kind of stuff that's
really a big part of the environment so
we looked at all these kids trying to
learn vb net in my course and we looked
for what we call insurmountable barriers
which is basically where they got stuck
and had to ask the TA for help we did
all sorts of coating of what they asked
about and what the problems were and
things like that and look for you know
what we could learn from the kinds of
things that they were stuck on and of
these we sampled the 130 barriers from
about what almost half of the students
and a lot of them they seemed like they
were able to overcome them themselves
but they actually overcame them wrong by
making false assumptions which then
ended up getting him stuck on something
that you know so I thought that I could
do this and then I got stuck so that's
that's this group here and then we kind
of classified them and stuff I got and
did the usual stuff and that we came up
with a set of six barriers I'm just
going to talk about a few of them there
were a lot of design barriers where the
students just didn't know how to program
something you know how would I actually
make this work and you know they do not
write a sort algorithm so you know it
really wasn't very surprising that they
got that all wrong they didn't know how
to do concurrency boolean logic again
showed up as a problem and could solve
this well you have to admit a lot of not
to do it right there's a built-in
sorting algorithm why should they write
one and you know so anytime you can
eliminate having to do some of these
kinds of things then you're really
helping your novice programmer but the
problem is of course thats leads
directly into the next problem is as
soon as you provide a sort routine and
so forth then they have to be able to
find it and so the selection barriers
were there must be something that does
this how do i find it or I don't know it
when I
you know how do I recognize it maybe I'm
calling it the wrong thing how do you
know how do I use it when I found it and
I wrote very robust finding this also is
true for experts is it when you don't
know how to do something finding an
example is much easier than finding a
whole bunch of documentation so here's a
good example one of the tasks was to
keep time on a clock and so they went to
msdn and typed in time and they got 500
results and that wasn't particularly
helpful and sure enough almost all these
have something to do with time but you
know which one do I want this is
basically useless might as well give up
at this point and it doesn't seem to be
ordered in any conditioning way so after
they found something they wanted to use
they overcome the selection barrier now
they have to know how to use it but
that's also hard as well what you know
what actions can I do with this how do I
set them up what effect will these
actions have and this is both in terms
of programming language constructs and
the AR it really wasn't a big
distinction in the users minds between
you know a do loop and the time function
because both of them are things they
have to learn how to do and they have
certain requirements and that kind of
thing so this distinction that computer
scientists have always made between the
language and the api's and you know
libraries really isn't very appropriate
in terms of how people learn to use
these because they have to learn them
all at the same time anyway and then
another thing that was really hard was
that I've got these two things and they
kind of work okay I kind of understand
them but how do I make them work
together and we call those coordination
barriers and there are all sorts of
rules in all these environments you know
this has to be called before this and
you can't do this and you know this is
true across all the api's we saw this
with the experts as well of course they
try to guess and they're almost always
wrong here's a good example if you have
two forms in vb there's no way to get
data to a form that hasn't been
instantiated yet okay so if you try and
push data you get a nullpointerexception
it has nothing jumped right or if you
try and get with ricos but anyway you
know if you have multiple forums you
know what do you do well you have to
global variables or something like that
because it's really hard to pass a
diagram also there were all these
language constructs using languages data
of different types and all sorts of
other examples and then their
understanding barriers which were no
surprise from our while I'm study that
you know what happened why did this
happen why didn't it happen you know
they added a timer but it didn't seem to
do anything you know why not so exactly
the kind of things at the white line we
already showed was good for so we took
all of these ideas and we were thinking
about reimplemented the y line for
professional designers professional
programmers meanwhile James Fogarty
another CMU student wanted to do a study
of interrupting programmers and so this
all came together really well and we
decided to do a study of how people help
of you know expert programmers you know
could perform a maintenance task what
were the actual steps that people did
and we're really focusing now on kind of
minute by minute maintenance tasks okay
so we're not talking about the
architectural design or the global
design or you know all the kind of big
software engineering things we're really
talking about you know I need to change
this feature you know what actual code
do i fiddle with them things like that
so it's an entirely different level than
most of the previous studies have been
looking at and we're looking at you know
all the interaction techniques around
the environment and I'm really proud to
say that Andy won the english paper
award it's us we go with this result so
we took 10 experts Java program or
self-described experts we didn't
actually verify that there were experts
but they probably were we use the clips
the program we had them we gave him five
tasks to do the route from fairly simple
two fairly difficult we pay them ten
dollars for each one they completed so
they were motivated to complete them in
any order and they used kind of the
standard tools for documentation
javadocs internet the
confuse Google to search for examples
and so forth we gave them 70 minutes and
they can do as many as they could we did
screen capture videos and about every
three minutes we interrupted them this
really helped and james's you know
resolve which he won a best paper award
a cognitive a second thoughts on that
but it's surprising that in fact data
shows that for real software engineers
this is realistic that a real program
was going to either interrupt himself or
be interrupted by somebody else pretty
much every three minutes with some other
test email comes in and I am comes in
the phone rings you decide to take a
walk or whatever and so it's fairly
realistic and in addition we were very
interested in what programmers do to
remind themselves about what they were
doing and you know what sort of tools do
programmers use keep track of stuff and
then this way we can really you know try
and build some of those into the
environment in a better way so the paint
application a fairly small program it's
only 500 lines and it could do certain
things but there were three bugs and two
new features that we asked people to
work on so we got these ten videos of
people and we had two different experts
encode them a fairly fine level of
detail and we got you know hundreds of
this is really laborious work we labeled
every user interface action in the
development environment itself every
navigation the people did when they were
reading code when they were switching
amongst environments when they were
testing so kind of every little action
the fuser didn't in a five minute and
here's how it broke down on average they
spend about twenty percent reading about
twenty percent anything about twenty
percent navigating thirteen percent
trying to find a new code that would
work for them looking at the api testing
so you know fairly little time testing
most of the time was trying to figure
out what was going on and we could break
down the actions this is one programmers
actual data into a various stages so
first they were trying to throw out
what's going on with this code so this
is code they're not familiar with they
have to figure out you know what part of
code is relevant then they're navigating
within that to really understand it more
detail and then the 5v they're editing
it we call this forming a working set I
Dixie we discovered people now we're
calling this concerns or something like
that there they are navigating
dependencies within that and then
finally they're doing a modification so
and of course these overlap in time so
here is all 508 lines of code and the
interesting thing here is a working set
for one particular application is spread
throughout all the files is this a bad
design in fact know that fundamentally
in all modern programming environments
you're required to spread out your code
of four new features you know throughout
the code imagine you're making the
button and blue new button goes in one
part the callback for that button goes
in another part the actual action that
does you're using model-view-controller
you have to add something in the model
you had something review you had
something to controller so there's
pretty much fundamentally required that
anything you do is really going to touch
code and mafia different places so the
first step was trying to form the
working sets you know how does this work
and they're trying to find in the code
which pieces do some tasks that they've
seen happen in the user interface and
they'd often make up words or think of
words maybe this is called pencil let me
search and see if i can find pencil but
only about fifty percent of their
searches actually led to the code that
was relevant to that because the
programmers weren't that good at
guessing what the word might be called
for dynamic things they would look for
why things didn't didn't happen and they
form hypotheses about what part of the
code was causing that but most of the
time they were wrong and so the result
of course is that people have a hard
time finding what code is relevant to
particular tasks then they want to
represent the working set so they
figured out now all those little pieces
of code that we saw in the picture that
are relevant how do they keep track of
that well you have halves in eclipse
where you can have little files open and
there's something equivalent
visual studio I'm sure and then there's
the bouncer this is the object browser
of a method you know inheritance browser
and then they would open often the files
the objects that they wanted to deal
with and try and use the fact that
they're open as a cue that this was what
they were dealing with but of course
this is fairly inefficient the more you
get open the harder it is to read them
the hardest keep track and this is by
file and often it's you know two or
three lines in that file somewhere so
then you lose track of that and of
course if they got stuck on one of their
paths and decide to switch to another
task and come back there's you know
working set is all messed up so what
about navigating in inside the working
set there were about 65 different
dependencies the people navigate on
average so this was a very common thing
that you would spend a lot of time going
back and forth you know from a call to
its definition from a variable to its
use things like that about half of them
were direct that eclipse actually has
built-in commands for each of these
kinds of navigation if you happen to
know what you're called or can find them
in the context menus you know
declaration of you spy called by
definition of but on the other hand
about half of them were indirect you
know find the method that computes the
value that passes this method that
amusing here and of course there's no
way to do that without you know
typically scrolling around and so forth
and in a modern environment you still
spend an enormous amount of time you
know navigating around to find all this
stuff and if you know each one it's
fairly quick and so if you ask a
programmer what's the hardest thing
about using the clips they're not going
to say I spend too much time scroll
right it's not something that people
have consciously in the front of their
head and I think this really comes to
the fact that it's not sufficient to
just ask programmers to introspect about
where they're losing all their
productivity about why aren't you
programming faster okay they spend
thirty five percent of their time
scrolling around in some sense
needlessly okay if you ask somebody are
you wasting a third of your time
scrolling around they're probably not
going to say yes that's exactly what I
need you to fix but in
fact when you do an analysis of this
level of detail you can see that this is
really a big time-waster for people and
so this is something that we're thinking
about addressing and you know how might
this work well programmers could
explicitly grab arbitrate fragments as
you grab a fragment of code it could
automatically bring in the dependencies
you know what's called by this what
where the declarations are put them all
in one place and so dependencies among
them support multiple working sets so
you can save save all this as unit I'm
going to call it you know task one or
you know the paint task and then so you
can switch back and forth that would be
really trivial of course integrate with
the y line so if you ask about something
you can bring in all the relevant code
into a working set and then you know
allow people to croon we've done a
painting of what this might look like
this isn't real obviously this is just a
painting and when we present the civic
SI there was a lot of concern about
whether scale up to real programs and
that's obviously something we're looking
at but this is a working set for one of
the halves that we have people do we
have copy and paste and there's all
sorts of stuff that's highlighted
they're looking for beef slider here and
things like that and there's a different
multiple working sets that you can
switch around through with a single
click so it's basically just a concept
of how you might take advantage of this
knowledge about what people are really
spending their time on to build a new
environment so one of the things we saw
in in our study of programmers which I
think I just heard you say is that
people would basically open new files
and get new tabs and they would not do
fine very maintenance of that they would
not close to certain ones of them that
they know their life open open open
until they get overwhelmed and they
close them all on a star like like so so
this
the programmers don't want to spend time
doing yes exactly right and so if you
see a lot of these ideas are basically
you start from some plates and the rest
is done automatically and so that's a
real interesting question as to what
extent can we tell from operations like
this is what I'm interested in or or you
know starting from the Y line and saying
here's the piece of code that's relevant
to this thing I'm doing now can we
generate a lot of the rest of this
automatically and I think that'll be a
real interesting to look at it would be
interesting to see as we increasingly
move into this more integrated
development world where we have visual
studio team system or something like
that would also have our bug tracking
also in the track that along with the
boredom sets that we use yeah that
barely understand we come back to a bug
on the section that we've used before we
couldn't say well maybe we need to save
working set because it looks like it's
the same kind of poetry exactly and I I
mean I think there's a lot of advantage
to saving these you know here's what I
use when I was fixing this problem and I
think you know there's no reason that
CVS kind of thing shouldn't say this
along with the other kinds of stuff that
you're saving in order to keep track of
what code is effective see any
indications of individual differences
programmers might be
might turn out to be I don't recall I
mean I I'd have to ask Andy that I don't
really know that's a good question you
know there's a lot of results that you
know their top down programmers and
bottom of programmers and all kinds of
so you'd certainly imagine it would be
and I don't really know to what extent
that affects this kind of behavior I
mean there was definitely now that I
remember there was definitely you know
some programmers who like to kind of go
through and understand everything before
they start working on stuff and other
programmers who would you know fiddle at
the local level but I don't see any
reason why this kind of cool wouldn't be
effective to those and it might you
might imagine you know to extend that
you could to have a tool and courage
whatever kind heard that to be more
effective you know getting a bigger over
the first I'm just going to see in
Visual Studio B to C team device
programmers and me
see them when you're working on farm in
these working sets legends in bavia you
see this court to which each type in
type programmer you know the school in
which they look for things that comes
today what they say some programmers
just looking for things I read the file
that are working with having a couple of
thousand project we are now beyond that
I said
what is it online okay now we have this
big videotape of all these professional
programmers doing stuff and we've used
it for two more studies the same you
know got this rich set of encoded data
one was looking at how people learn
api's and it turns out people much
prefer to go to examples then to use the
documentation and in fact people often
use Google instead of msdn or Java Docs
in order to search and why is that well
a lot of it has to do with the
vocabulary problem no people are trying
to get this thing to fade out so they
look for fade out and sure enough they
find sound stuff right and so they look
for transparency and they don't find
anything so if I you know how are they
going to know to find alpha as a thing
to cause things to fade out well if you
go to Google then it turns out that
people often find people often have
asked this question and newsgroups and
somebody's answered oh well you and so
Google turned out to be a really good
way of solving this vocabulary problem
and most of the things that you find
with Google or questions and sometimes
with the answers and often that turns
out to a really effective way but of
course a lot of irrelevant stuff is
returned to even if you had a great
search tool like you're still going to
get all this irrelevant stuff and you
know there are also multiple methods you
know they're even if you got exactly the
you have a really high precision there
are really three or four different ways
of doing time that all are perfectly
appropriate in in visual basic which
ones right for me a lot of it depends on
your context and so people want to use
examples and so our idea of is to use
the context of what you're trying to
program and some more elaborate
techniques to try and use Google as a
way of identifying exactly what kind of
information what kind of example should
be returned and so that's something Jeff
is just starting to working now in terms
of making a new programming environment
we want to keep track of lots of stuff
in order to make the wireline work in
this working set stuff work and it turns
out that it's very hard to keep track of
that kind of things if you have a plain
text editor
like the visual studio text editor
because whenever even though it can do
some things like you know highlighting
and it can do incremental parsing as
soon as there's a typo or as soon as you
type a single character such as the
parts fails it has to throw away and
lose all sorts of information because
now it doesn't really know where the
code is anymore so we were wondering in
Alice on the other hand you can keep
track of everything and it does all this
great stuff about eliminating syntax
errors and things like that but it's
been known for 40 years since the
beginning of when people start first
trying to make structured editors that
although they can be really good for
creating code and you can get
professional programmers to create code
enormous rates with tools like this
they're really abysmal for maintenance
and of course most the time is really a
maintenance so is there any way of
finding something in the middle that
combines the advantages of both plain
text editing and fully structured edit
well no one's really succeeded that why
don't we do a real low-level study to
see when people are editing when
professionals experts are editing code
what do they do and so we did this a
very detailed level analysis of 700
minutes of people programming in eclipse
with Java you know 2700 individual text
editors and there is in fact a lot of
structure that people use when they're
doing this editing and the full
flexibility of free text editing is not
necessarily required for even for expert
programmers when they're editing code
they're certain cases you do need full
flexibility so people love to edit their
names and other names and they want to
do all sorts of stuff there that's
pretty easy to support they often will
use text editing operations to wrap and
unwrap code and I want this in the loop
where one hour loop you know things like
that so we have to be able to support
that really easily which structure
editors make very difficult and I want
to move three of these four elements
into a loop you know how do you do that
but people rarely and text edit it
across structure boundaries people just
don't edit their Wiles in the ipps which
is kind of the fundamental thing that
people are wondering about
dr. Davis and you know if you have an
easy way of doing this and maybe you
don't have to do that because they can
just make a while and move all the code
they want to end it ninety-eight percent
of selections of bait structural
boundaries people almost never you know
selected a piece of the wind and the
piece of the if they followed it you
know and part of the same thing and try
to do some weird everything with that so
there is a lot of structure in the way
people edit code and maybe we can use
that it's a way of creating a new editor
and that's kind of what Andy is doing
now is thinking about interaction
techniques that take advantage of what
we can in terms of the way people edit
make some operations even faster than
they are now you know if you want to
move some code why not have that as a
single operation that's so fundamental
and then really be able to preserve some
of the advantages of structure
everything but I think this is going to
be a really interesting thing Andy's
working on that summer so let's put all
this together in a new programming
environment the goal will be to make it
significantly more effective and
productive for programming both for
professional programmers novice
programmers I guess this is all and end
user programs okay what do they have in
common what do they need this different
we'll use the semi structured text
editing we'll think about all these
barriers to learning and ways to remove
those so that will make it better for
beginners but also for novices in terms
of learning new api's and things like
that we'll have built-in support for
working sets so that you know as you're
trying to do maintenance tasks it'll be
easier obviously we'll put in the Y line
we have a bunch of other ideas that
we've come up with in terms of copy and
paste and other kinds of tools that we
think will be useful and I think it'll
be really exciting so hopefully I'll be
able to come back and tell you about all
the cool things we've done environment
so in summary i think there's no way we
would have come up with a lot of these
ideas or these tools if we hadn't done
these really detailed studies of
programmers in the analysis in advance
and so doing these studies first provide
lots of new insights not to new
knowledge that otherwise we wouldn't
have and I so it's really a very
effective way of getting out yours but
it is very labora
yes I mean it has taken this you know
hours and hours of analysis of hours and
hours would take to come up with it what
we are able to see what people really do
which is very different from what they
say they do or if you ask them what
they're doing what their problems are
what they'll tell you so you know this
really goes back to the ati principles
we're always teaching our students at
CMU that you know it's not sufficient
just to ask people what they want you
get the marketing data from that but if
you observe them then you'll really find
out what they really need and that's
really what we're focusing on here we
really think that our new designs are
going to be more effective for all these
groups but of course we definitely will
be doing the studies to try and you know
detail the actual improvements we get
and won't be you know just randomly
claiming the setter without the actual
data to pack it up but we certainly will
expect to you know we're hoping we'll
get dramatic results like we did for the
wire line where we're getting you know
really big numbers in terms of fertility
and that's all we didn't even bother to
ask people what they were doing I mean
we had people you know doing tokelau
think-aloud protocols and so what they
say they're doing minute to minute was
very useful you know oh I'm looking for
this bug oh I want to know why this
didn't happen and so that's in the
initial study how we knew that almost
all the questions were why questions and
why not questions other one wouldn't
necessarily have known what they were
going at but the point is that if you
ask a programmer to think fact what was
a hard thing to debug or what you need
out of your programming environment
they're going to tell you this you know
hard bugs they had that you know took
them a week to divide you know 62 years
ago and sure enough that you know be
great if the programming environment
helped with that but you know what have
they done the last two years and is
taking thirty-five percent of time
that's not something that people really
introspect about it kind of goes to the
old mantra that and I think some of the
other students were really married you
were looking this right good if people
that
the hard mental operations seem like
they take a long time and all this
clicking around doesn't seem like it
takes any time at all so you know if
people have a really hard mental pass
they're going to think that takes them a
long time but in fact they're really
wasting all their time clicking around
and so if you just ask people you know
what was hard about that they're going
to tell you what took them all came to
figure out and you know that'd be great
to fix that with some of the design
problems you know give them better tools
but if you really want to make them more
productive you know make the rest of the
stuff go away so it can spend more time
bringing these design problems so here
Microsoft you go to your people who can
start to take some measurements and this
offer has a Lisbon composed of the kinds
of operations that would be helpful for
us to to measure to yeah definitely the
the papers about the studies you know go
into somewhat detail and I'd be
delighted to give you more detail about
what we encoded you know the minute by
minute operations are and to extent that
those could be detected automatically if
these whole lot better than detecting
them from you know videos as that was
really boils and so I think there's a
lot of things that can be recorded that
would be useful you turn on recording
and have somebody to a caster measured
over a long period time because I think
you know one of the obvious criticisms
of this that you know I certainly
resonate to is you know well you justed
lab studies you know how does this
really apply to somebody doing a 10,000
or a million line program and you know
we just say well we think it is but when
I'm sure so you know to accept it while
we're you guys have data that really
backs us up and says yeah it's the same
thing even though you're dealing with a
10,000 line program when you're fixing
an individual bug it's really only you
know 50 lines you have to deal with
right now that would be really useful or
you know it really is a dramatically
different thing and so you have to take
this into account when you're doing
something it's a new design so if I was
a case we took we want to know what I've
had from dance
what is Andy graduating he's uh he's not
expecting to graduate for two years so
about two years ago because you know a
lot of so we have this API program and
there's a whole bunch of students who
are first you know who are on the first
class to graduate will probably graduate
next year so he was thinking about it
but decided he'd really wants to make a
really comprehensive tool and then test
it and it's really not likely that will
happen in here yeah Andy's a real
superstar and I think we're going to see
some really exciting tools is result did
you call it using natural language for
things like asking questions for the
line or navigation to encode yeah that's
a really important point is that we did
not we definitely didn't want to go you
know to natural language that you know
obviously what people want to say is you
know you know make pac-man you know eat
the big dot when he runs over it and
what if you could just say that then you
wouldn't need all this programming right
or you know you want to have natural
language questions too and so we're not
really doing AI part of this project so
we didn't really want to go that route
so the question was how can we put
things in the Y line it'll be clear and
luckily and I guess this goes to your
question a little bit too in the Alice
environment all the method names have
very well-designed of names the method
several design names so all we had to do
was put the methods in the menus and
people knew immediately what they wanted
to do you know why didn't pack move well
we didn't have to say that we just said
why didn't the pack move to method big
called basically and so that worked out
really well and that language was more
obscure naming conventions it might be
more interesting to think about what has
to go in the menu to make it clear what
you're asking about well
I expect the white line to do in cases
where pack resize occurs in multiple
places and code my alliances of why
didn't pack resize yeah yeah so
currently it just asked about the last
occurrence but obviously that's not
nearly good enough in the environment
where something happens 10,000 times and
one of them is long you know and there's
other work around CMU it Mary Shaw and
my former student Rob Miller was looking
at anomalous behaviors and you know can
you automatically identify behaviors
that are different for some reason and
that would make a lot of sense to embed
that in this that if something happened
a whole bunch of times you combine them
into this big group that happened with
zero and the southern big group that
happened with one or false and true or
something that we haven't really done
much with clustering but that would make
a lot of sense to do for some things
that are caused happen a lot of
different time it also see scenarios
were there pieces were packed tried to
resize the smaller and that didn't
happen yet pack recessed a larger did
happens to write back resize wound up
being in the line and why not well that
often happens well in fact it always
happens because everything in the did
menu also goes into didn't menu just
because people we found so many so often
people who thinks of stuff didn't happen
that actually did and you saw that twice
those are real scenarios by the way they
can come out long you see that all the
time surprisingly there were no false
propositions of people thinking
something did happen that didn't so that
we didn't have to put the didn't stuff
to know did menu right but yeah I think
you know that's one of many many
questions that will have to deal with
when we try and scale us up to
professional environments so when you're
your study of people fixing bugs in that
you didn't really say too much about the
effect that the interruptions every
three minutes paddle programmers what
were the big bullet results there so the
interruptions who are designed such that
you could not respond to them so it's
more like an IM that you could answer if
you wanted to but you didn't have to
unlike like the phone or something and
so we definitely saw people trying to
delay their answering it and but they
got a lot of money if they answer the
questions right so there was a big
motivation to answer the interruptions
you know it was designed you know to
make that you I think you got like you
know you could really lose a lot of
money by not answering any questions
yeah they were motivated to answer the
question and they hired mental
operations so that would completely
clear out your you know working memory
so you know basically was doing a
two-digit multiplication problem in your
head people would try a lot of
interesting strategies in terms of
maintaining where they were do they put
you know the selection in the code they
put you know bad text in the code so
that they compile it would fail on it
they would try and mark you know the
code so they would remember what they
were doing so a lot of the strategies
like this you know we really want to
support the environment to help people
you know regain their working set
basically retain their what they were
doing the James Fogarty's results were
that people would try when they were in
the middle of an editing operation they
would try and wait until they were done
with it or if they were scrolling to
find something they finish finding it
and then accept the interruption so they
would often delay by 30 seconds or so
until they finish whatever mental
operation they were in progress on and
so you know that finally what changed is
looking for us you know can we detect
automatically and you know that would be
possible actually he discovered it that
was the Chi paper that in fact a lot of
the stuff that you need to know when
would be a good time to interrupt is
available to the programming
itself it's when you're scrolling when
your text editing you know things with
that but you must have seen things where
people would delay in order to say
finish a fine that they were doing yeah
in a row then they come back and say now
why did I try to find this thing again
what I want to do with it right right so
you've blown out there their short-term
exactly and so where I don't exactly
remember all the details of that but
they're definitely some things that we
think we could put into the program
environment to help with you know some
things about what you're doing now give
a feel for how much more productive they
would have been if they took
interruptions or if you do any went to
that well we certainly know yeah I think
this is a measure certainly how much
time they spent in the eruptions and I
think there's a measure of how much time
it took them to get restarted but I
don't remember it off Hannah that's a
week no internet no we didn't do that a
probably given the small data sets it
probably wouldn't have been saying you
know Cicely significant the differences
between the two groups i would just my
intuition but you know that would be
excited to run
no thanks